his speech last night President Trump
said this is a quote let us set aside
our differences and seek common ground
is what he said yeah Trump said this
because like any good speaker he always
likes to open with a joke it's a these
people up a little bit
softens the mood kind of I'm just gone
just kidding
I'm gonna tweet crap about all you in
ten minutes says that and then as he's
leaving the podium ass screw alia today
it was reported that President Trump
State of the Union address was the most
tweeted in history most tweeted in
history yeah when he was told this Trump
said suck it Abraham Lincoln that guy
got no tweets he's got nothing going in
last night's speech President Trump
reportedly didn't stray from the
teleprompter once not once Wow yeah
friends are saying it's the longest
Donald Trump has stayed faithful to
anything
she was like Ellen's political today
[Applause]
google has a new service called flights
have you heard about this it's called
flights that is now able to predict
flight delays not cool yeah here's how
it works if you're flying United your
flights delayed California is looking
into creating a state bank for the legal
marijuana industry
[Applause]
just like I don't like that I like that
I don't like that no they're creating a
bank for the marijuana industry yeah
they're going to call it the California
Bank of dank stank
last week a she's getting more airtime
tonight than I am yeah yeah she cut her
a check last week a school in England
get this last week a school in England
accidentally showed pornography to its
students instead of the Paddington movie
yeah well the good news is either way
the kids learned about bears
meant to explain that one and II know I
don't
you